comme tous les étés depuis 50 ans les
terrasses de saint tropez font le plein
les touristes admirent les yachts et les
jeunes viennent faire la fête
lorenzo et angelo ont à peine 20 ans ils
sont cousins et ils sont originaires de
lyon avec leurs copains aurélien ils
sont en vacances dans la région
et dès qu'ils le peuvent ils viennent
sur le port se frotter aux parfums des
milliardaires pour s'éclater
pour se mettre la tête à l'envers
lavande a choisi ce bar cet été c'est
ici qu'il faut se montrer et commandé
deux grosses bouteilles
ça ça vaut 400 euros
550 euros ça c'est 50 aux 150 on ya plus
de 700 morts à la faute les amis le nec
plus ultra pour ces jeunes gens c'est
d'être entouré de jolies filles
il croit avoir trouvé la recette
afficher un maximum de bouteilles chanel
venez voir mais ramène tes copines
il ne faut pas ça tous les soirs en fait
angelo a moins d'argent qu'on pourrait
le croire pour pouvoir se payer ces
soirées il enchaîne les petits boulots
on travaille comme des dingues on se
lève à 6h du matin ont fait 9 heures 10
heures 11 heures par jour mais le soir
on décompresse
on gaspille tout en bouteille voilà ça
trompe et c'est ça qui a trouvé cette
travail et après c'est la folie le soir
on se contrôle plus
[Musique]
l'été c'est la saison pour frimer se
montrer se faire remarquer
sur les plages dans les soirées
dans les bars ou dans les boutiques
c'est le moment ou jamais pour exister
dans le regard des autres
il faut être beau original
sexy
la théorie de vos gosses ses costards
cravates chemises belmont mais surtout
pour se faire remarquer aujourd'hui il
faut dépenser de l'argent montrer son
flic sortir billets et cartes bleues
claqué
jolies filles payet bling bling
l'argent doit se voir c'est une montre
qui vaut 85000 euros et elle est toute
faite à la main dans nos ateliers à
paris bref il faut que ça en jette
et ne pas oublier non plus de frimer sur
les réseaux sociaux
plus de huit jeunes français sur dix
seraient aujourd'hui accro à facebook
twitter
instagram stade chat tout le monde peut
aujourd'hui se mettre en scène pour la
planète entière devenir le héros de sa
propre histoire virtuel on fait des
photos qu'on va mettre sur facebook que
ça c'est là comme tu vois c'est le règne
des cfi ses autoportraits postés sur les
réseaux sociaux des images pour dire
regardez comme ma vie est belle
regardez comme je suis riche flambé pour
exister
quitte à montrer une vie parfois bien
éloignée de la réalité c'est toi qui as
prélassant prend la commande
en quête d'une gloire illusoire ou d'une
fortune a claqué son lit vite ils ont un
été pour tout flamber
[Musique]
cela fait plusieurs étaient maintenant
que angelo et son cousin lorenzo font
les saisons pour pouvoir s'éclater le
soir le patron du bar vincent les
connais bien
le maire huit boss ibos j'ai même vu
livré en début de saison est libre et
les pizzas
il va aussi après veut traquer ses sous
dans une soirée ma poire mais c'est un
bosseur il est debout tous les matins et
puis frétard le son équipe
ils n'en n'ont pas les moyens et
pourtant ils flambent
pour le psychanalyste michael stora rien
d'absurde
bien au contraire ils sont jeunes gens
20 ans on n'a qu'une seule fois 20 ans
on a besoin d'une certaine manière de
brûler l'argent comme une manière
d'exister comme aller très vite en
voiture une sorte de peut-être de
d'étourdissement qui fait qu'on oublie
ce temps là qui on est certains prennent
de la drogue
eux ils dépensent de l'argent deux
heures du matin trois bouteilles et deux
magnums de vodka plus tard la bande de
copains est toujours en pleine forme et
ils ne sont pas près d'aller se coucher
mais dans le groupe il y en a un qui est
rentré plus tôt il est 5 heures il part
travailler c'est lorenzo
c'est dur c'est dire deux mois après des
présélections et c'est fascinant
[Applaudissements]
il faut dire que le changement
d'ambiance est un peu rude
tous les matins lorenzo est apprenti
boulanger pour gagner les deux mille
euros qu'il dépensera en quelques heures
dans les restaurants et les boîtes de
saint tropez
il doit d'abord beaucoup travaillé donc
ça c'est toutes les commandes
là je dois faire la plage de tahiti
s'affairent le camping des tournelles
c'est à ramatuelle et je finis rossier
par le carolo ses instincts boslak à
cavalaire si lorenzo n'a aucun problème
pour se repérer dans la région de saint
tropez c'est que depuis longtemps sa
famille est une habituée de ce coin
meetic de la côte ces mâts par an et
m'ont parlé de saint tropez monsieur
quand il était petit z est souvent ici
c'est dans un camping qui s'appelle le
conti qui es tu tombes connaît
saint-tropez il ya toutes les stars et
et moi j'avais vraiment envie d'y aller
un jour mes parents m'ont dit bombe à
cet été on t'emmène à saint tropez
tamponne ramatuelle l'âge des salles en
chaque matin lorenzo traverse des
endroits qui font rêver
là je vois ça tous les matins quand je
vais livrer sa de vue des fois je
m'arrête je mange un croissant et je
voyage j'admire cette immersion au
milieu des vacanciers fortunés loin de
déprimer lorenzo elles lui donnent
plutôt des ailes au revoir mon objectif
c'est déjà de réussir dans la vie et
quatre heures plus tard un peut-être un
jeune comme moi viendra me livrer et je
me dirais avant je faisais ça maintenant
je suis de l'autre côté je profite
son cousin angelo a trouvé lui aussi un
job de saisonniers il commence un peu
moins tôt le matin et travaille dans une
pizzeria à saint tropez en genre alors
la salade
voilà monsieur depuis trois semaines
angelo le flambeur et serveurs la
journée voilà pas là c'est toi qui as
prélassent entre la commande
le jeune homme débite des coquards des
salades et des pizzas dix heures par
jour avec une pause d'une heure entre
les serveurs ou midi et du soir
c'est le prix à payer pour pouvoir
sortir certains soirs quand il a gagné
assez d'argent
je viens je travaille je m'arrache
mariage mariage m'arrache et quand la
paix y arrive
voilà on va l'argent je vais faire
plaisir on va s'acheter des vêtements
valeur à la plage soirée restaurant
basse et le c'est le fruit du travail
comme on dit c'est pour ça que j'aime
faire des saisons j'aime travailler et
j'aime dépensé derrière mon argent on va
pour d'autres il n'est pas nécessaire de
travailler pour pouvoir flambée l'été
nous sommes dans une des banlieues les
plus chics de l'ouest parisien au
vésinet kevin à vatan
il vient de terminer son année en école
de commerce et c'est le moment de penser
aux vacances
cet après midi et réunions de
préparation avec deux de ses meilleurs
amis
laurent aimard kaka actuellement la
bande de copains fait partie de ce que
l'on appelle la jeunesse dorée signe
particulier leurs parents sont tous très
aisés sont les gages anti blanc
le père de laurent et chefs d'entreprise
au menu cet après-midi la préparation
des vacances et le programme de l'été
s'annonce appétits sont avec un séjour à
saint tropez et à cannes est un
impératif dépenser le maximum d'argent
et bien le montrer bref flambée fort sur
le sol par les meilleures tables et bien
passé c'est des moments pour nous ouais
on veut tous les étés et l'ambiance ne
ça change pas on se retrouve comme on
dit vas y à tous on vote les break final
si les retrouver parisienne il est la
vraie parisienne du quartier ouest de
paris
concrètement etienne 7e 6e 16e
changement la versa
kevin surnommé sakho et laurent joue les
blasés mais il ya quand même quelque
chose que les excite encore montré qu'il
flambe sur les réseaux sociaux type le
dos à dos allez allez pose comme
d'habitude le petit peu
peut il pose comme sac officielle sur
facebook
il faut il à 2000 j'ai effectivement ça
monte vite
attention à ne pas prendre ces jeunes
gens à la légère sur facebook
kevin est une vraie star il a quatre
compte 2000 a mis des centaines de
photos publiées et les milliers de
commentaires
kevin a aussi un compte twitter et une
page youtube où l'on peut constater
qu'il aime la fête des pins piliers dean
sa g où il se fait appeler 'prince of
italy on peut les admirer par exemple en
peignoir léopard cigare au bec dans
quelques jours il part faire la fête à
cannes et saint-tropez
ce matin il a besoin de sa maman maman à
20 ans il n'est pas très au point pour
faire sa valise
si je n'en mettrais sur plage france ça
j'aime pas ça c'est beau il faut dire
que l'exercice
quand on est très préoccupé de son look
requiert une certaine expérience oms à
l'esl et puis c'est pas vraiment un
choix there il tient beaucoup à son
image mais ceci dit il a toujours quand
même été attirés par ce qu'ils étaient
voilà mes même tout petit l'aimé bien
quand même les choses assez statique
kevin parent pour plusieurs semaines
il n'oublie pas son objet fétiche un
doudou d'un genre un peu particulier un
gamin ma bouteille ça c'est ma bouteille
ça c'est une bouteille personnalisée en
fait qu'est ce c'est mes initiales
souvenir c'est en plus on sait pas très
lourd 1
non c'est la guerre toujours avec moi ça
mars et lassée des personnes s'est dit
peu enfin certains préfèrent amener des
peluches des porte-clés des voilà moi
c'est moi c'est cette petite bouteille
d'eau plaignants 2002 que j'aime avoir
posé ici
kevin aime étaler son luxe son enveloppe
financière pour les vacances est en
conséquence j'ai pas un budget précis
puisque c'est vrai que ça part très très
longtemps en côte d'azur avec le bateau
le shopping avec les restaurants les
dîners la piscine la plage plage privée
ça part très très vite c'est mon argent
en là ça qui est bien les parents de
kevin sont divorcés depuis plusieurs
années son père est riche alors quand il
n'a plus d'argent le jeune homme s'est
toujours à quelle porte frapper
ben quand il y en a plus y en a plus non
mais bon moi déjà parlé non moins bien
sûr que non non mais c'est apparemment
par doudou t-shirt lunettes de soleil la
valise est bouclée et c'est parti
direction saint tropez
kevin le gamin riche fait partager à
tous son programme de jet setteur sur
les réseaux sociaux
capri milla en cannes saint-tropez mon
planning est plus chargé que mes valises
bonnes vacances à tous simplicité
s'abstenir
[Musique]
sur la côte d'azur tous les flambeurs
n'ont pas les moyens de kevin
[Musique]
c'est dans cette petite maison orange
ans que les deux cousins lyonnais ont
élu domicile chez les parents de lorenzo
nous sommes à une dizaine de kilomètres
de saint tropez à la croix valmer une
bourgade beaucoup plus populaires
pendant les deux mois d'été les cousins
sont inséparables ce qui les réunit
c'est le goût de la fête
moi je suis un grand tour les vêtements
les voitures les sorties tout au tout
après je confie je dirais qu'elle savait
beaucoup d'argent j'achèterais un temps
cabriolet direct mais mais c'est vrai
que heureusement j'ai pas beaucoup
d'argent ce que je crois que là tu es là
sera moi je ferai des trucs
inimaginables
aujourd'hui on chez lou ne travaille pas
c'est l'anniversaire des 20 ans de son
cousin lorenzo ça devait venir mes
baskets château et le programme c'est de
ne rien se refuser
rendez vous a été pris à pampelonne
l'une des plages les plus chers de saint
tropez
ouais plus vite tu peux être comme ça
moins vite comme ça ça marche
prix de l'heure sur cette bouée 120
euros
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
mais peu importe aujourd'hui les jeunes
gens sont décidés à ne pas compter et
accomplira ses amis voilà
soit 200 à voir le tous cas mais l'un
des amis là-bas voir souvent lan être
prétentieux comme ils ne sont pas faire
plaisir à tout le monde
j'ai quelques pas des millions d'euros
avec le peu que j'ai je fais profiter ma
famille comme moi c'est un adversaire
voilà j'essaie de faire le plaisir du
moment où il sourire mignon c'est vrai
la chance et une chance en or et en
argent comptant quatre agents d'affaires
l'argent en faire profiter la famille
les amis ceux qui sont vraiment au prix
fort le nombre de joueurs ouais tu peux
monter sur batimat équipe à l'arrière du
bateau
pour les jeunes yonnais c'est l'occasion
de s'initier à l'activité hype du moment
un drôle d'engin qui donne l'illusion de
marcher sur l'eau
enfin presque le fly board 90 euros par
personne pour seulement 20 minutes d'
équilibre très instable
passionné
ces tueries ça fait des nouvelles
sensations on va rentrer et on va se
préparer parce que là on a rendez vous
au restaurant pour ceux nés anniversaire
et après en faire une bonne soirée et on
va entrer comme à faire jour cadorette
l'artolie selon jusque là fait
apparemment s'annonce bonne
les jeunes gens ont prévu de passer la
soirée dans leur club préféré à saint
tropez chez vincent derrière ses airs de
rocker à la cool
vincent le propriétaire est une des
figures de la vilaine ils animent les
fêtes tropézienne depuis plus de 20 ans
avec sa femme cathy il a construit sa
réputation à force de travail et de
nuits blanches
je suis issu d'un milieu d'ouvriers
j'ai moi même bosser quand j'avais 14
ans j'ai bossé à l' usine est pas rien
j'ai bossé de 14 à 20 ans à l usine
donc je sais ce que c'est que gagner de
l'argent d'aller chercher de travail et
pour ça on a vu beaucoup de choses hein
on a vu des milliardaires des russes des
pensées des additions à 150000 euros 200
mille euros à côté de nous ça on l'a vu
donc ça ça m'a choqué un peu au début
maintenant on s'habitue à tout ça me
choque un peu moins mais en même temps
je tiens un établissement de nuit
donc on peut pas non plus cracher dans
la soupe et non ça me choque plus ça me
choque plus je préfèrerais confie se
fasse par parcours pour attirer l'argent
des vacanciers vincent mise sur le
bouche à oreille et la publicité
tee-shirts casquettes mais pas seulement
pour faire parler de sa boîte de nuit
cette année il a été chercher son
inspiration à courchevel
on amène cet été les bonnet de ski
ces sites c'est à dire que sur les
plages les filles portaient des bonnets
avec les maillots de bain quant au wild
jolie fille je vais pas hésiter à donner
une casquette ou un tee shirt je vais
et parce que je sais qu'il va être bien
porté je sais que c'est représentatif et
je sais que je veux qu'on voit des
belles filles à la plage avec nos
casquettes ou nos t-shirts elles se
prennent en photo avec et ça se partage
sur facebook etc
facebook c'est c'est quelque chose
d'incroyable quoi depuis peu vincent
s'est en effet converti au bling-bling
2.0 son club a ouvert récemment une page
facebook des photos de bar un peu vide
quelques clients pas de quoi bluffer en
tous les cas
emery doligé spécialiste de la
réputation sur internet il au début
arriver vraiment tout au début parce que
l'appui il utilise 20 5 % de la
puissance de facebook est à peine de
photos il ya les vidéos elles sont
cachées la communauté réagit pas
beaucoup pour chaque poste publié sur
facebook qu'il faut quand même qu'il y
ait un certain nombre de pourcentage des
gens qui soient présents et qui
interagissent avec là on est des
chiffres qui sont même pas intéressant
de regarder puisque on frôle les 2 %
donc c'est rien il ya encore beaucoup de
travail sur facebook pour arriver à
faire quelque chose il ya un vrai
potentiel
donc il ya un sujet qui est la fête la
nuit la jeunesse donc il est au coeur de
cible des gens qui sont sur facebook
les grands principes pour faire en sorte
qu'une soirée buzz sont un peu toujours
les mêmes c'est qu'il faut qu'il y ait
une dimension people
il faut qu'il y ait une dimension humour
il faut qu'il y ait une dimension
exceptionnelle
et ça ça passe par des photos pas on
raconte l'histoire sur la page fan du
tsar on ne raconte pas d'histoires c'est
juste plaquer donc il manque quelque
chose
oui donc il était une fois on a besoin
de lundi était une fois quand arrive le
soir
vince on retrouve son élément la nuit et
il met son habit de lumière
son job c'est aussi d'être vu ce soir il
emmène son fils antoine dans une belle
villa de saint tropez
pour ce qui est supposé être une des
grosses soirées de l'été
là c'est chez plutôt sous le signe de la
culture j'imagine ça va être un peu plus
je crois on va dans une villa où tout ce
qui est dans cette soirée est en vente
aux enchères est avant tout il va y
voyant des ventes ou des ventes aux
enchères
tout est à vendre y compris la villa bon
il a quand même qui est à côté de la
messardière chez pas au bas mot comme ça
moi je dirais que ça coûte au minimum 20
millions d'euros vincent a tout connu de
l'âge d'or de saint tropez
il a participé au célèbre soirée blanche
du producteur eddie barclay
il a dansé jusqu'au bout de la nuit avec
eddy johnny et bien d'autres
pendant longtemps ce sont les frasques
des stars plus que l'argent qui ont fait
la réputation de saint tropez
vincent travaille dans la nuit depuis
plus de 25 ans et croit en connaître
tous les codes
pourtant ce soir il va être surpris
voyez on a déjà des voitures qui sont
garées là devant donc on arrive on
arrive devant toi merci
comme tout invités qui se respecte
vincent un carton d'invitation mais à la
porte
il n'est pas tout seul loin de là très
strictes et s'est plaint tous essayent
vincent a beau avoir une invitation
apparemment ça ne rentre pas ça c'est le
style des soirées je vous expliquais il
invite 500 personnes pour être sûr d'en
avoir trois cents tu vois ils ont la vie
de 500 pourriture de 1 300 une fois
qu'ils ont fait le quota il passe un
coup de téléphone pour tenter de
débloquer la situation
peine perdue les quatre qui sont sortis
je les connais bien s'ils sont sortis
c'est qu'ils se sont fait chier ça je
peux te le dire pas facile de se faire
traiter comme un invité ordinaire
surtout devant une caméra
alors au bout de quelques minutes
vincent perd patience voilà on va pas
s'emmerder pourquoi s'emmerder leur
genre de truc ça c'était la soirée vidéo
donc regarde bien ça c'est les nouvelles
soirées de sa trompe et c'est les
nouvelles soirées les parvenus
il faut acheter des masques à des gens
tu vois aller par les bidons donc qu'est
ce qu'on fait avec ses invitations de
merde on les déchire
parce que c'était une soirée de merde
allez on se casse merci ça tu l'aurais
jamais vu à l'époque de barclay par
exemple toi ça c'est des les nouveaux
parvenus les les trucs plus tard sa
trompe et c'est aussi ça retour sur le
port de saint-tropez dans le club de
vincent il est un peu plus de 22h et il
est encore tôt nous démarre très très
tard ici un donc c'est déjà un
établissement qui est fermé la journée
on a un créneau que faire le chiffre
entre 10h30 11h et trois ordinateurs la
quatre heures pour faire le chiffre est
là pendant quatre heures faut pas se
louper
à minuit l'endroit est bondé depuis le
début de l'été antoine le fils de
vincent est aux commandes du club aux
côtés de son père des charges et de
l'ambiance et des relations avec les
clients
demain je veux que la clé par rapport
aux gens faut être là pour les
accueillir
[Musique]
la pme de vincent c family business
c'est cathy sa femme qui est derrière le
bar
sur les tables à une heure du matin
l'alcool coule à flots
et la famille commence à penser à son
tiroir caisse
[Musique]
j'en passe
après rang
m
c'est difficile ce travail qu'on va pas
et l'a fait à saint tropez quelque chose
que personne n'a fait prendre à un bar
en vrai c'est à vélo que robert placard
à balais un couloir et transformés comme
ça
[Applaudissements]
des animateurs se démène pour amuser la
galerie
vincent lui n'oublie pas son compte sur
les réseaux sociaux
on paie des photos qu'on va mettre sur
facebook que ça c'est la com du roi
[Applaudissements]
les photos de cette soirée seront dans
quelques minutes sur la page du club de
vincent
de quoi donner envie aux fêtards même
ceux qui viennent de très loin
[Musique]
c'est le cadeau kevin il vient tout
juste d'atterrir en provenance d'italie
il retrouve son ami laurent c'est parti
pour des semaines de vidéos et de photos
sur le net
là il roule en voiture sans permis
j'ai peut-être un petit bonjour
là il fait du jet ski tout pour épater
les copains
kevin rose parfois seul parfois
accompagnés pour michael stora c'est
comme s'il était plus important de
montrer ce que l'on vit plutôt que d'en
profiter dans le réel
[Musique]
cette idée qu'il faut que les choses
pour qu'elles existent il faut qu'elle
soit prise en photo qu'elle soit filmé
et c'est ça qu'on repère c'est vraiment
cette question là que les réseaux
sociaux viennent nous montrer et le
nombre de commentaires la qualité des
commentaires le nombre de like sont
comme une forme de 10 matin tim qui
permet à tous ces jeunes à ce moment-là
de confirmer que il existe bien à
l'image de ce qu'ils veulent donner à
voir dans la vraie vie ce que donne à
voir kevin ce jour là c'est un peu grâce
à son ami laurent
il est hébergé dans la villa de ses
parents il passe tous ses après-midi sur
le bateau de son père aux hôtels a alors
atteint un des chefs les chiens étaient
vraiment alliant de merde ton en france
[Musique]
sur un bateau il ne sait rien faire
bon d'accord
la rga l'avant à l'avant mais ne semble
pas s'en formaliser
tandis que son copain essaie de sortir
du port kevin se prélassent sans
complexe sur une banquette
ouais un peu stressé là des petites
manoeuvres dans le port là c'était
fascinant feu à trois mois de permis il
affiche une assurance déconcertante
quitte même à part être déconnecté de la
réalité
je prends du recul je vois que sur tout
en me comparant aux autres personnes je
réussis je comprends et je vois
effectivement on a un peu un niveau au
dessus par fois qu'on vit tous les jours
ce train de vie que je mène mois depuis
trois quatre ans va pas content après
c'est d'en moyenne de conventions comme
un autre
on a affaire à quelqu'un qui est né dans
les anses qui nous le montre bien qu'il
n'a aucune culpabilité ni honte par
rapport au fait qu'il est fils de riches
ils l'affichent ils le montrent il en
jouit tout va bien
une fois en mer pas un instant à perdre
pour kevin
le jeune homme n'oublie surtout pas
d'immortaliser l'instant
prenez votre téléphone
voilà l'image mais elle ne semble pas
complètement eu clair les bataves d'un
porte clés saisis
pourtant kevin va tout de même la poster
pour informer ses dix mille familles
instagram
il recevra 333 like ces photos je suis
moi je sais pas après par rapport à mon
image certaine éducation donnée avec mon
a fait les écrans une étude américaine a
montré que facebook pouvait avoir un
effet des précieux gêne parce que
justement on a besoin évidemment des
autres mais le lien virtuel est un lien
qui n'est pas suffisant on a besoin à un
moment ou un autre de l'autre dans la
réalité
je pense que beaucoup de personnes qui
postent énormément de choses sont en
attente de commentaire
c'est comme une forme de validation de
confirmation parce que d'une certaine
manière c'est comme quand je poste
quelque chose c'est comme si je
m'adresser à vous et que vous ne me
répondez pas d'une certaine manière ça
vous renvoie un sentiment de solitude
totalement intense
[Musique]
pour finir la journée
direction une boîte de nuit de cannes
soit tellement ça soit son nom de ben
oui sur la même une voix wiltord les sd
pour être acceptée la réservation peine
samantha montreux
le cérémonial est bien réglé kevin et
ses amis vont commander un maximum de
bouteilles d'alcool
on va aller leur servir avec des feux de
bengale pour bien qu'on les voir ils
vont faire beaucoup de photos pour
pouvoir les montrer à leurs amis
jamais avare d'un petit coup de frime
kevin pas les photos en dollars
[Musique]
à la fin de la soirée kevin et ses amis
auront dépensé une grosses sommes
comme il se doit ce soir ça nous a coûté
environ 2400 euros
on a pris un mannequin de don pérignon
un amalgame de belvédère s'est
simplement les plaisirs qu'on s'accorde
des personnes qui s'accordait plaisir en
partant voyager autour du monde en
lâchant des vêtements nous l'occurrence
et voilà jeté une bouteille boire un
champagne entre amis mais peut-être que
plus tard en évoluant j'aurai d'autres
types le plaisir le golf un sport les
voyages ça peut être très variable
je me pose la question à quel point il
ya de l'ironie ou pas et j'ai
l'impression qu'on n'a pas du tout à ça
indique à ce moment là qu'on a plus
aucun recul la conscience que vouloir
faire dépenser l'équivalent de deux fois
le smic ou à peine une demi heure
dans més à ces questions est oui mais
les gens vont voir vos coupe et couture
et course a bien sûr un jour conscience
de la réalité des choses de la crise
deux des smic c'est bien sûr après mal à
l'aise a conscience que si marvel mais
après tu fais la nuit se terminera
autour d'un dernier verre sur un bateau
avec des jeunes filles rencontrées dans
la boîte de nuit
[Musique]
garçons et filles regardent les photos
de la soirée des paillettes encore
raccrocher aux yeux les paillettes le
bling bling
taylor chiche en a fait son métier nous
sommes à paris place vendôme dans le
salon d'essayage d'un des couturiers les
plus chics de la capitale un saint des
saints où seuls les gros clients sont à
taylor chicha 28 ans et apparemment son
apparence le préoccupe beaucoup
son business il faut dire c'est la haye
la mode voilà comment il se présente aux
internautes qui cliquent telle heure
chiche sur youtube montre de prix bijoux
cigare un je ne sais quoi d'artistes
dans le regard
l'homme se donne l'alluré d'une gravure
de mode entre chic et clinquant
en fait son cv est plus prosaïque il
organise des soirées dans des boîtes de
nuit à la mode et dirige plusieurs
restaurants branchés son mot d'ordre
le bling bling et la communication
[Musique]
aujourd'hui taylor chiche a déjà pu
s'offrir certains de ses rêves d'enfant
ep voiture j'ai toujours vu dans les
magazines quand j'étais gosse mon père
m'ont montré dans la rue voilà c'est sur
quelque chose que j'ai eu envie d'avoir
une belle voiture fait partie d'eux
entre guillemets de l'artillerie du luxe
et
dès que j'ai pu m'en acheter une c'est
vrai que ça a été mon entre guillemets
mon
mon premier et mon premier achat qu il
nous emmène place du marché saint-honoré
le quartier des touristes et du luxe
c'est là qu'il a ouvert il ya trois ans
un restaurant la parisienne
donc c'était un restaurant qui était
totalement à l'abandon j'ai fait
quasiment six mois travaux entre la
démolition et la rénovation et j'ai
vraiment fait à l'image
que je voulais qu'elle est vraiment j'ai
choisi eux
chaque chose
afin de l'image chaque chose à mon
animal ce matin taylor fait visiter les
derniers aménagements de son
établissement à une copine
l'assistante du couturier le succès de
l'endroit tiens surtout à sa réputation
qu entretient soigneusement taylor
l'acteur américain mickey rourke
le footballeur djibril cissé l'acteur
jean dujardin il y à des stars partout
en photos sur les murs et aussi dit-on
dans la salle
tout tourne autour des pipoles mois par
sont des amis à moi et on a fait les
photos pendant les travaux
une de mes préférées c'est celle de
jibril en fait j'aime ce couteau parce
que tu dois manger un plat de chez moi
en l'occurrence terme de plateforme et
pas trop d'élections que l'envergure la
parisienne
servi dans sa boîte tient plus
aujourd'hui les gens s'identifient
vachement personnalité et
et qui vont ça fait toujours monde ce
soit au niveau de la presse que ce soit
au niveau des gens tous les jours c'est
un gage de valence sur taylor est parti
de zéro
il a commencé à se faire un carnet
d'adressés dans le showbiz à l'âge de 20
ans à la faveur d'un séjour chez des
amis de son père à los angeles
aujourd'hui il s'est bâti un des plus
brillants réseau de star de businessman
et de noctambules de paris qu'il fait
venir dans ces soirées et ses
restaurants
et là il ya quelques semaines toujours à
mon restaurant avec avec jamie foxx
c'est robert de niro qui me voyaient là
pour la première fois au mois de janvier
donc du coup si tu dois quand un mec
comme de niro qui t'envoient qui tombera
quelqu'un bon
vis-à-vis de la personne tu as touché
plus de crédibilité ce sens que c'est
lui qui t'appelle pour réserver et non
pas toi qui court après la personne pour
pour la voir sur les réseaux sociaux
son restaurant se veut l'endroit où l'on
croise à coup sûr des célébrités
pharrell williams lenny kravitz jamie
foxx robert de niro
aujourd'hui c'est une vraie cantine
d'artistes quand tu viens déjeuner ou
dîner tu es sûr de rencontrer quelqu'un
voilà un chanteur un acteur peu importe
mais tu es sûr de effectivement
rencontré quelqu'un la parisienne c'est
un restaurant mais pas seulement
c'est aussi le nom des soirées qu'il
organise un nom qui en jette qui fait
rêver pour des soirées à la recette
somme toute très classique de l'alcool
des jolies filles plutôt dénudée et des
clients fortunés
ce soir la fête a lieu dans une boîte du
quartier des champs elysées il est 23h
et taylor commence sa journée de travail
ça peut surprendre mais taylor on va
passer la majeure partie de la nuit
postés à l'entrée du club
en fait un endroit stratégique pour
sélectionner et bichonner sa clientèle
au début son rêve toujours à la porte
c'est qui et qui voilà je j'arrive à
à voir qui est bon client du coup je les
attrape avant
avant ce qui se passe confuse et où
avant de se passe là coeur wild fabas et
le petit groupe ce soir tayler chiché
pays en fonction de la recette de la
soirée
alors les bons clients lui et son équipe
ont intérêt à bien les repérer vous êtes
messieurs allez y messieurs vrai gros
spender et sont là à partir de
2h30 3h du mat très gros spender ça veut
dire les gros dépensiers ceux qui nous
font aux chiffres
ceux qui nous font chiffon à la main si
on a le chiffre la macif et maif
déclinant parce que tu le net dans le
vip à côté d'une tête de la liste ouais
bien sûr car mais sont ils sont deux
garçons de 5 points parce que si on
achetait à ce succès bon sauf que ses
gros clients
ilan il ya une très belle table tu as un
côté des meufs dont on carey hart et les
meufs et le staff de taylor sait
parfaitement ce qu'est une bonne table
veulent taille pour que ça soit
accompagnée ok les filles il faut que
les clients sont sympas sont beaux il
faut au minimum de 1000 euros
deux heures du matin après avoir
contrôlé les entrées taylor va
maintenant vérifier qu'à l'intérieur ses
amis il est gros portefeuilles ne manque
de rien taylor connaît bien son métier
mais c'est que les gros clients veulent
se sentir différent des autres il faut
les saluer
ce soir il ya du monde
encore faut-il que ce monde consomme une
préoccupation que le personnel de taylor
a toujours en tête
[Musique]
pas nous
il a une
[Musique]
les talons
les relations
la consigne a le mérite d'être clair les
fêtes de taylor sont devenus une marque
une marque qui tente aujourd'hui
d'exporter dans le monde entier dans
quelques jours il va tenter sa chance
pour la première fois à cannes une ville
où les flambeurs les spender les gros
clients devraient être nombreux
sur la planète bling bling tout le monde
rêve d'être riches et célèbres réseaux
sociaux casting en tout genre télé
crochet la notoriété le succès semble à
portée de la main et les candidats à la
gloire sont prêtes à tout pour y goûter
alors les anges ont dit nos bouts de
l'eau
c'est le cas de joy elle a 18 ans après
avoir vécu aux états unis elle revient
aujourd'hui vivre en france avec ses
parents et une obsession devenir une
star de la chanson
la nouvelle céline dion ce matin elle
retrouve sa cousine marie est tout de
suite joy tient à lui en mettre plein la
vue et plein les oreilles
là je vais te montrer une chanson que
j'ai fait avec mon produit soeur à new
york il s'appelle live et
voilà je suis excusé toi de me dire si
c'est elle qui fit sa sé on l'a écrite
ensemble ans en fait sans aucun complexe
joyce se lance dans un show a cappella
en plein milieu du restaurant
[Musique]
beaucoup de gens si c'est dans cette
vidéo
joy a toujours voulu être célèbre
elle a d'abord essayé d'être championne
de tennis aux états unis
sans succès
elle s'est reconvertie dans la chanson
de variété et là ça a commencé à mordre
elle a réussi à glisser un de ses titres
sur la bande son d'un film d'hollywood
pour se faire connaître elle multiplie
les photos qui en jettent sur les
réseaux sociaux
à l'avant première d'un film à cannes
sur le capot d'une grosse voiture là
avec la salette people paris s'il tonne
ici sur la terrasse d'un grand joaillier
ou encore la chanteuse sexy aujourd'hui
c'est pratiquement impossible de s'en
sortir sans les réseaux sociaux on a
besoin de twitter de facebook
ces mêmes propos de youtube pour
commencer à se faire connaître il faut
mettre des photos dire ce qu'on fait
tous les jours si on va il fait dire
qu'on va une fête mois socialiser ou
pouvoir partager ce qu'on fait on est
obligé de les utiliser des réseaux
sociaux
la quête de célébrité de joy est quelque
chose qui est assez couru chez les
jeunes femmes les jeunes hommes de la
génération dorée la façon dont elles
utilisent les réseaux sociaux monde
qu'elle est au tout début de sa démarche
et que déjà hélas elles a une identité
sociale c'est à dire qu'on la retrouve
sur instagram tour sur twitter on la
retrouve sur facebook donc déjà elle
pose les premiers jalons de sa
communication
maintenant faut vraiment qu'elle monte
en puissance si elle veut se démarquer
de tout ce qu'ils font exactement la
même chose qu'elles et ils sont
plusieurs dizaines de centaines de
milliers moi je suis prête à tout pour
réussir en tout cas je m'en donner les
moyens et
et voilà comme je disais on est beaucoup
dans ce monde donc je taperai à toutes
les portes nécessaire jusqu'à ce qu'on
accepte pour se faire un carnet d
adresse et pas seulement sur le net
la jeune chanteuse est à l'affût de la
moindre opportunité ce jour là elle a
réussi à obtenir par un copain de
copains une invitation pour un défilé de
mode lors de la fashion week et ciron
avec sa mère revient c'est le plaisir de
doigts alors normal non ils étaient
juste astérix le chercher grâce à l'ami
antoine un garçon visiblement très
branchée elle a réussi à se faire placer
au premier rang
je vais essayer de rencontrer le maximum
de personnes et prendre contact avec le
maximum de gens pour voir ce que ces
français peuvent m'apporter
c'est une opportunité incroyable
les mannequins et leurs tenues ne semble
guère passionnée joy
ce qui l'intéresse c'est quelqu'un
d'autre le créateur qui fait défiler sa
collection s'appelle luis bush i know i
les portugais c'est un couturier qui
monte et joy a bien l'intention de le
coincer en coulisses pour se faire
connaître et même de lui proposer de
faire la musique de son prochain défilé
après quelques minutes de chasse elle va
réussir à l'aborder sans aucun complexe
bonjour loïc monsieur bush i know mon
nom enjoy
bonjour à vide pour rencontrer c'est mon
ami mais je suis une artiste chanteuse
et j'aimerais pouvoir vous faire écouter
ce que je fais pas de problème on a un
site internet avec tous les contacts
je vais vous envoyer un mail c'est
vraiment un beau défilé les mannequins
sont superbes
merci merci d'être venu à la prochaine
pas sûr que joy face la musique du
prochain défilé de louise bush i know en
revanche la presse internationale et là
il ya des caméras partout et tu as
réussi un tour de force des journalistes
l'interview alors qu'ils n'ont même
jamais entendu parler d'elle
les russes télé portugaise à mon nom de
scène ces jo y est je suis artiste
auteur compositeur
j'ai maintenant 18 ans et j'essaye de me
promouvoir un petit peu partout c'est
comme si jo y avait fait ça toute sa vie
à la fin du défilé
la jeune fille repart avec ce qu'elle
était venue chercher ce potager j'ai
quatre cartes de visite un qui me
propose de tourner une vidéo de musique
appareils et un autre qui veut qui est
dans la mode qui travaille pour je sais
plus quoi ce que je veux la rime et les
gens n'aient un email avec ce que je
fais comme quoi aller au fashion weeks
and said les artistes les artistes en
mettant bien sûr le défilé ouais pendant
la fashion week
la jeune chanteuse va multiplier les
défilés en quête de nouveaux contacts
elle va même réussir à se faire inviter
pour l'inauguration d'une boutique de
mode à cannes la mecque de la célébrité
rendez vous est pris quelques jours plus
tard
sur la côte d'azur retour à la croix
valmer à quelques kilomètres de saint
tropez dans la maison des deux cousins
lyonnais ce soir on fête l'anniversaire
de lorenzo lorenzo tu peux devait
dépêcher se plaire en finn se maquillait
savon pour les filles comme pour les
garçons
ce soir il faut être au beau vous est
longue
[Musique]
j'ai même pas vraiment angelo et lorenzo
connaissent bien les codes de l'élégance
il croit savoir ce qu'il faut porter
pour séduire plaire et impressionner la
terrine beau gosse et costard cravate
chemise belles montres voilà là plus
rien à dire comme ça c'est saint tropez
quoi c'est la classe
tout ce qui brille le bling bling voilà
une console samedi bancs se fait plaisir
la rolex la même façon ce qu'on rien je
suis une personne seule elle cela montre
c'est ça les jeux sur les charmes de
l'âme c'est la maj tony gomez anime les
soirées parisiennes et tropéziennes
depuis plus de 25 ans il connaît par
coeur les codes de la nuit bling bling
on est dans une société où les codes
sont très importants j'ai presque à dire
qu'on est dans une société de symboles
et les symboles sont un raccourci qui
veut dire beaucoup de choses
la montre la marque le look la vaysse la
coupe on appartient forcément une tribu
et là on est un peu dans cette prime
dans dans l'élégance entre guillemets
dans le luxe
on veut on veut par est riche ce soir
les deux cousins semblent aussi
préoccupés de leur look que leurs
copines
mais si on est des femmes 1,7 inquiète
pas tu sais ma copains c'est cette
mission enfin le voir un vieux pprama
coupe des cheveux c'est vrai tu te
rappelles avant personne ne l'avait
cette coupe maintenant comme une lame à
coupe au bout d'une heure les garçons
sont enfin prêts en bas de l'escalier
le comité d'accueil est enthousiaste
[Musique]
toute la famille passent l'été dans le
sud sa sortie de montres bijoux les
montres les bouteilles en boîte de nuit
cela fait beaucoup d'argent mais la
famille a l'habitude des fois la paix
passe en trois jours en trois jours la
bei à l'huile à sa place en 3 enfin ils
ont compris que pour ferme pour avoir
pour le plaisir il faut qu'il passe
comme ça c'est ça qui garde sait que
c'est faux pas contre ce qu'il doit s'en
aller avec la cuillère en or dans la
bouche
déjà on n'aura pas plus leur donner
l'argent que les week-ends à sortir déjà
ces deux choses a qu'une vie au temps
mon fils que les fleurs après trente ans
tu fais un enfant tu fais ta vie tu
remets la dystrophine contres à fond
julie la petite amie de lorenzo est la
dernière à être prête
lorenzo a droit une première surprise
aux sept mini décapotable loué pour
aller en ville
comment je la prends jettent une attaque
s angelo a réservé dans un restaurant du
port et ensuite une table au tsar le
club de vincent
mais pour que la panoplie d'effets
l'état reçoit vraiment complète monte
encore un accessoire toujours ton petit
ya un ingrédient indispensable de faire
la différence
ce qu'ils fument tous les jours qui
viennent je coupe tu allumes et
repartent avec ils font la fête
jaguar mais vu le cigare c'est ça fait
toute une élégance à ta classe
de commandes et à l'italienne comme chez
nous des cigares cubains 20 euros la
pièce pour sept mois il entraîne trois
c'est pour filmer pour ce soir c'est pas
tous les jours quand c'est ce plaisir là
non
quand je pense aux tailleur voilà on en
profite pour le psychanalyste michael
stora ce qu'il faut noter en particulier
c'est la taille de l'accessoire le
cigare en effet fait partie je pense d
imagerie d'un d'un luxe à l'heure pour
le coup moins clinquant sauf qu'ils sont
tellement gros leurs cigares j'ai
l'impression qu'ils ne choisissent pas
forcément en question de la qualité du
vrai plaisir mais plutôt du fait que
c'est un gros cigare comme une grosse
montre et ça fait partie de ces objets
bon le cigare peut-être qu'on peut voir
aussi une dimension phallique je ne sais
quoi en tout cas quelque chose qui
montre à quel point on a une certaine
puissance
pour l'avant des cousins le rendez vous
a été fixé sur le port de saint-tropez
achats retard c'est l'heure de l'apéro
moi je prends la section dabitch
[Musique]
voix
santé
[Musique]
les mots
ça commence bien les verts flandre les
tournées s'enchaînent
après quelques cocktails et plusieurs
verres de vodka
tout le monde est au mieux de sa forme
jusqu'au moment de l'addition
[Musique]
hélas angelo marque un peu le trou
trois mois passés
on a ça promet elle est brisée
à
la barre en matière sur deux
de france mais c'est comme si
derek la caf et son trident
chaque enfant
l'addition est plus salée quand j'ai
l'eau ne l'avait prévu les copains sont
bons princes
tout le monde met la main à la poche
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
arrivé au sort l'endroit est déjà noire
de monde
mais le maître des lieux vincent leur a
réservé sa meilleure table
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le temps d'allumer leur cigare
de commander quelques magnats or la
bande de copains et bien non de la croix
valmer de la pizzeria et de la
boulangerie le temps d'une soirée les
cousins lyonnais deviennent les rois de
la nuit tropézienne
falloir mener quand même l'addition
quand même une bonne note il va falloir
discuter avec de monte cristo
pour l'addition vent sont accordés une
petite ristourne en l'honneur de
l'anniversaire mais angelo doit tout de
même débourser plus de 1000 euros
presque le montant de son salaire de
serveurs à la pizzeria mais là il tient
parole et il sort sa carte bleue
[Musique]
à
la soirée restera longtemps dans les
mémoires
[Applaudissements]
je retrouve cette ambiance mais à
l'époque on savait on faisait la fête ne
savaient pas qu'ils paient on était très
discret sur le avait toujours des
mécènes qu'organiser des grandes fêtes y
en avait un qui était à éviter tout
saint tropez on nous demandait d'être
baude et élégant d'être amusant et on
nous demande et surtout pas de dire
merci
hélas ce qui est drôle c'est notre
société a changé maintenant j'ai dépensé
tant d'ailleurs c'est ce que je dis
souvent en parlant certains patrons de
boîtes de nuit j vous êtes des marchands
de meubles et des amis avant quand un
client rentrée tu veux une table qui
voit là on lui donnait la table
maintenant c'est devant des tables j'ai
une table à 2000 j'ai une table à 1000
on est dans un autre rapport nous
retrouvons taylor chiche à cannes ce
soir ils organisent une des grandes
fêtes de l'été sa première sur la côte
d'azur
plus encore qu'à paris il faut que son
nom soit impeccable
il faut que ça claque
que ça brille alors direction la
boutique d'un grand joaillier installé
dans un palace cannois
alors ça va bien tu es venu à cannes tu
achètes pour le week end je suis une
petite soirée demain j'ai besoin de
temps quelques débordements je fais
une soirée sur cannes et donc j'ai un
petit peu d'accessoires d'accord on va
en votre équipe et vous allez bien ça
et doit on a onze est un bijoutier
spécialisé dans les people
il fournit notamment peuvent daddy
madonna ou encore sharon stone est
question bling bling
edouard naoum en connaît un rayon ça
monte et ça c'est beau et ça c'est le
complètement dans le tempo c'est
complètement con style et je pense que
là elle est membre demain pour une belle
soirée
tous avaient dit avant moi un pavage
compliqué tout de même sanchez à la
longue c'est une montre qui vaut 85000
euros et elle est toute faite à la main
dans nos ateliers à paris pour les
clients privilégiés à céder ces terrains
prochaine
tu as quand même très bon venez pas me
jeter leur intérêt à la nouvelle gauche
à droite et toujours cette tendance
monsieur taylor
je veux bien vous la position je pense
que c'est à la fois soft et les grands
pas c'est qu'en fait ça menaçait sans
fioritures en sélectionnant ne croyez
pas que telle au ray edwards soit
seulement des amis ils sont cent à faire
et ne s'en cachent pas ils se renvoient
les clients comme on se renvoie
l'ascenseur
j'ai des clients que je lui envoie est
lui aussi réciproquement il m'envoie les
clients on s'envoie relais des familles
bien entendu yves c'est une bonne
vitrine pour moi taylor il porte des
bijoux ou tu as acheté ça fait ch
edouard nahum donc effectivement on
retrouve régulièrement des ptt des gens
qui viennent de ses bras de ces deux
formations qui mènent à chercher connu
voilà ce qui m'a ainsi qu'edouard c'est
qu'il a vraiment des très très bon
client
et dès que on lui demande où il faut
sortir dans la minute qui suit j'ai un
coup de téléphone des douars ou un sms
voire qui me dit cette personne va
t'appeler donc du coup
suite pour moi c'est magnifique c'est
des clients qui tombent entre guillemets
tout seul non merci - doit maintenant je
te fais un bisou doctement que dans tu
passe demain la montre bien sûr taylor
ne l'achète pas ils l'empruntent pour la
soirée la fête qu'il organise
il faut le dire promet d'être bien
fréquentée à cannes il ya une
concentration de tous ces gros spender
voilà sur sur un kilomètre de croisette
est bon c'est assez facile de les avoir
pour moi ils sont là pour dépenser de
l'argent
quant à un gros client il faut entre
guillemets
attiser le feu et
pour que ça prenne si tu as un mec qui
dépensent je dis n'importe quoi 50000
euros
trente mille euros cent mille euros le
mec est à côté qui est aussi richissime
que lui va se sentir un peu lésé vas-y
remet à temps
je passe inaperçu donc il va vouloir se
chauffer effectivement dépensé forcément
plus que lui mais après ça reste une
bataille à quelques heures du début de
la soirée
taylor a rendez vous avec gwendal le
propriétaire du club où doit avoir lieu
la fête
mieux qu'un bureau la plage peut
s'avérer être le meilleur endroit pour
orchestrer la promotion d'une soirée je
conçois
oui et
on est samedi ont fait c2c de 22 heures
à 2 heures 30 et après acheteur
important de quatre heures il faut
matraquer les gens le jour j de la
soirée pour dire on est là on est là on
est là venez venez mené convaincre des
jolie fille devenir c'est bien mais il
faut surtout faire venir ceux qui vont
flamber
vous êtes en tension cannes super
combiné ce soir la soirée très très
bonne soirée soir
à tout à l'heure où je te remercie je
l'appelle indiens etc c'est que je suis
qui
impression actuellement ce qui va
dépenser je vais l'accueillir je vais
l'installer et je vais passer le voir
une deux fois dans la soirée qui se
passe bien voir c'est que je vaux
présent
mais je pense qu'il faut c'est une
petite table
huit et dix mille euros je pense
aujourd'hui pour communiquer il ne faut
pas grand chose
un stylo une pancarte et une photo ça
peut suffire
alors on va le faire après tu vas au
front en train de le lien qui vient de
serrer
[Musique]
voilà
coûte la photo en fait ça me c1
communiquer surtout mes réseaux sociaux
et à prévenir que ce soir
la soirée se passe babylon et là tu vois
rien qu'avec ça j'ai déjà touché à peu
près de 2000 personnes et ça m'a pris à
peine deux minutes grâce aux réseaux
sociaux l'information circule en
quelques secondes
lancer une fête n'a plus rien à voir
avec ce qui se faisait auparavant
fini le bricolage vive le 2 avant on
était sur une plage des jolies jeunes
gens passaient avec des flyers et nous
les confirmés emmener ce soir ça va être
super cool hier en étant une
communication du média donc aujourd'hui
on est dans une communication de hyper
médias j'ai besoin d'avoir des gens qui
vont porter cette communication le plus
loin possible dans les réseaux sociaux
ce qu'on appelle le buzz le buzz c'est
quoi c'est l'effet d'une goutte d'eau
qui tombent sur une flaque et il ya eu
cette petite oscillation mais chaque
oscillations dans les réseaux sociaux
est porté par une personne et l'objectif
c'est évidemment c'est que l'oscillation
est le plus loin possible
taylor m'envoie un message c'est ce
message là il me plaît je la revois ma
communauté dans cette communauté à une
personne ça lui plaît et ses tweets
retweete facebook
instagram sur ses tablettes sur son
smartphone
taylor est à fond aucun réseau social ne
lui résiste
encore faut-il choisir le bon en
fonction du réseau sur ce que vous allez
utiliser ces des communications qui
n'ont rien à voir
il est clair que sur facebook vous allez
créer une histoire vous allez créer une
communauté vous allez en est un monde
sur twitter ça va être beaucoup plus
rapide c'est de l'hyper médias c'est du
tout de suite le tweet va avoir une
durée de vie de quelques minutes voire
quelques secondes
et puis un autre va elle va le chasser
sur instagram on est sûr de la photo on
prend plus de temps on peut communiquer
d'une façon différente il n'y a pas de
bon ou mauvais réseaux sociaux il ya un
endroit où vous êtes connus ou pas
connus hier que typiquement ci
surviennent sur instagram
vous avez plusieurs dizaines de milliers
de followers sur instagram et que vous
avez personnes sur twitter vous allez
communiqué ou bas sur instagram donc
tout et où je me trouve et où est la
communauté qui m'entourent et donc je
vais communiquer sur s'attendre on l'a
à cannes il est 22h30 les premiers
fêtards arrive
et comme à paris c'était lors qu'ils
supervisent les entrées du club françois
l'intérieur
les gens commencent à arriver une belle
voiture des jolies filles
voilà une belle table qui s'annonce ça
c'est une petite table qui vient une
dizaine de
dizaine de modèles avec
quelques promoteurs et de très bons
clients donc c'est parfait pour
commencer pour la soirée avec un
abattoir et là encore un autre gros
client en nous qui arrive qui a fait une
belle réservation il aura même réussi à
faire venir quelques gros clients de
paris nice et là c'est pas toi tu vas
au fur et à mesure que la nuit avance le
club se remplit les clients consomment
l'argent rentre d'ailleurs à l'entrée on
commence même à refuser du monde
c'est le côté ce soir mais il ne sera
pas possible ici mais ce n'est qu'après
il peut bien c'est pas moi qui m'occupe
de la porte et a beaucoup misé
c'est compliqué dlr ouais je m'occupe de
la porte bien sûr je fais rentrer tout
le monde mais c'est vrai que pour
écourter la conversation à ce temps ci
je préfère dire à la personne etc ou
s'isoler je m'occupe pas de la porte
que me prendre la tête lui expliquer
c'est con si ses courses et rapide
elle rentre en demie parce que si chaque
personne vient me voir et me fait me
rend précisément entre ça ça va pas le
faire je préfère moi faire ma sélection
à l'entrée avec avec mon fils et ma sécu
et que personne n'intervienne dans ce
que je fais mais oui c'est je préfère
écouter les concessions en disant écoute
m'occupe pas de la porte on l'espère les
physios alors complet pour certains mais
pas pour tout le monde
[Musique]
à 3 heures du matin
le succès se confirme mais le jeune
businessman garde toujours une poire
pour la soif
il lui reste une table de disponible
encore faut-il avoir les moyens de se
l'offrir
this fall 10 cbl était à nouveau quand
j'arrive à la fin d'une soirée il
mourrait sur deux tables j'annonce un
prix fort parce qu'aujourd'hui mon
chiffre est déjà fait donc je préfère
lui dire que ma dernière table mais dans
la droiture de 2000 euros je préfère m
et à ce moment là
à ce moment là voilà et c'est devant la
table hier matin il fait bientôt jours
mais ce n'est pas encore l'heure pour
taylor de lâcher la faire c'est vrai que
je préfère rester jusqu'à la fin la
soirée pour voir que tout se passe bien
que les filles ont tous bien réglé donc
pas qu'on ait des crédits
et puis je préfère dormir tranquille la
firme asseoir et attendre que le plus
gros soit parti les coins il reste
quelques tables je m'échappe ray
tranquillement mais
voilà je préfère rester jusqu'au bout à
8 heures du matin
cette fois la fête est finie c'est
l'heure pour les noctambules de rentrer
se coucher dans deux jours taylor
s'envole pour dubaï
il va et tenter une expérience organisé
une soirée branchée dans un émirat du
golfe
quelques heures plus tard toujours à
cannes nous retrouvons joy
la jeune chanteuse et sa mère
grâce à une connaissance zhai a réussi à
se faire inviter pour l'inauguration
d'une boutique de mode en plein centre
ville
elle compte bien y faire des rencontres
on lui avait parlé de la présence d'une
personnalité miss côte d'azur
elle demande à se faire présenter
[Musique]
sans la moindre hésitation
joy déroule l'intégralité de sa bio
[Musique]
non
je suis né à paris mais j'avais tous les
dix ans et je
et à miami en prépa d'une musique été
choisi pour un film
qu'ils s'appellent
deux photos
mon frère qui crée un buzz en ce moment
sur la même position de twilight que le
produit est ma chanson à ma chanson elle
a été choisie pour être la chanson du
générique du film en fait j'écoute
bonheur voilà on rendrait vraiment
devant déclarations en garde
comme ça il ne manque pas de culot elle
va demander à essayer quelques modèles
de la nouvelle collection pour son futur
show dit elle on ne sait jamais
fellah sur pied après deux mois sans
rouler qu'est-ce qu'on pourrait choisir
pour benoît l'entrepôt exactement alors
de fond de chanteuse
mardi il va arriver
avec cette musique c'est cibler un petit
côté requins on est pauvre et pourquoi
alors là où c'est impossible
parce que ça
ça irait
ça si on est sous son nez sur scène et
comme on chante ça permet au bras
[Musique]
tandis que ça ça aide
on ne peut pas lui enlever ça la jeune
fille a un certain talent pour attirer
la lumière et elle n'en reste pas là
elle demande aux dj ni plus ni moins que
de passer une de ses chansons
[Musique]
celui nommé
et dans cette boutique de cannes
entendre sa chanson diffusée pour joy
c'est un peu une consécration
je suis passé
pas content et m'amuser avec soufflet
c'est marrant de voir
la suite se modérer
c'est superbe leçon lundi on voulait
m'enrôler mois
dépassés
selon l'avenir l'avenir du futur bien
dans son corps
on ne peut pas être mauvais si elle a un
talent
ok le
quel prouver que j'en suis sûr
d'ailleurs est vraiment une fille mais
c'est très très bien
c'est très important si la motivation
sérieux mais cette jeune proche la
connaît comme ça a toujours été comme ça
elle est très à l'aise
elle rencontre les gens et fédère des
gens tournent m
iran dans son monde qui vont pas dans
son rôle et se voyant dans son monde
c'est ça cette jolie pour finir en
beauté
joy réussit même à se glisser sur la
photo officielle de la soirée
[Musique]
en plein milieu
la photo sera dans la presse le
lendemain
[Musique]
mais pas ses mots
[Applaudissements]
l'info tout est dans arrête
[Musique]
j'entendais
cette fête maman voilée
j'adore
ça va gagner à 5000 km de là dubai une
des villes phares des émirats du golfe
persique
et hiller chiche sont associés odorantes
et son dj débarque du vol de paris
ils viennent pour 48 heures le temps
d'une fête
un des hôtels les plus réputés de la
ville a demandé aux jeunes français
d'organiser pour un soir ça fait la
parisienne qui commence à s'exporter un
peu partout dans le monde
bon c'est pas mal de pas mal de traces
et marrakech cannes milan londres
dubaï qui arriverait en compte on est on
est dans vraiment dans les endroits où
ça se passe en 3e place to be en ce
moment du bac c'est
pisani comme oswald ça devient une place
de fait vraiment important
si la fête est un succès taylor et son
associé s'ouvrirait les portes du golfe
persique
un nouveau marché réputé pour ses
dollars et ses gros spender ses bons
clients
à peine arrivé à l'hôtel le français se
mettent au travail
les portes de la boîte ouvre dans moins
de quatre heures et il n'a pas une
minute à perdre quelques heures avant ce
que je poste les dernies fire dernier
visuel qu'on assure sur l'événement pour
pour encore dire ce soir ça se passe au
cristal venez et c'est la montre de prix
est bien au rendez vous mais le jeune
homme a troqué sa panoplie noir habituel
contre une veste couleur sable comme le
désert ça fait plus locale avant la
soirée telle ans a rendez vous dans un
restaurant japonais dans un étage de
cette tour
[Musique]
la vue est imprenable c'est inler prend
le temps de faire une photo
[Musique]
elle et son fils elle va être postés
directement sur les réseaux sociaux
thello a rendez vous avec une amie iman
c'est une française elle est installée
depuis peu dans les émirats
ça va elle travaille pour un hôtel de
luxe et c'est elle qui a fait venir t il
or en fait j'avais reçu un ami à moi qui
ai bbox pour la énième fois dans mon
restaurant et elle avait posté tapoter a
posté la photo n'en ai posté la photo
donc se rassurera les réseaux sociaux
mais je crois que testons
patron ou le directeur qui voit qu'il
avait relancé qui la veut dire qu'il va
devoir être copain taylor et matt ont
vraiment été séduit dès lors être d'être
une célébrité grâce aux réseaux sociaux
on est venus de très loin pour cette
fête titi un ami de taylor apparemment
très riche raconte qu'il est venu
spécialement de new york pour la soirée
de son ami titi et mon avis mon frérot
ce que tu veux
monde entier les sept continents les
continents
on est en septembre
ça
c'est dans un comptoir
dakar - des importations
s'il rate enchères à dubaï l'alcool est
strictement interdit dans les lieux
publics et les fêtes sont organisées
dans des hôtels internationaux on y va
il ya
c'est la première fois que taylor et son
associé travail dans ces conditions ils
ne connaissent quasiment personne alors
ils ne sont pas très rassurée pour le
succès de leur soirée un peu trop si
c'est pas même si c'est pas notre
établissement c'est pas chez nous comme
à paris mais voilà de quoi qu'il se
passe on veut que ça marche on a voilà
on doit quand même le palais pour après
à l'étranger c'est surtout la peur du
vide
exactement ce que tu sais que tu es
attendu que noah y est arrivé et là y'a
personne
bon je te rassure ça nous est jamais
arrivé mais il ya toujours une personne
dans la salle bah la moindre djellaba ni
le moindre kéfié très peu de
ressortissants locaux
les filles sont très peu vêtues et le
champagne coule à flots on pourrait se
croire à paris wasquehal
et d'ailleurs comme à paris ténors ne
quitte pas son smartphone toujours cette
obsession du buzz
[Musique]
d'après alain tanner regard de ma
famille qui lobait la carte
on la cherche
ouais
la grande force des réseaux sociaux
c'est que ça fait perdurer la soirée
vous avez eu la soirée qui s'est passé
l'événement qui s'est passé et après on
va leur raconter sur le film on la
montre
on fait des photos ont fait en sorte
qu'il y ait des gens qui viennent
témoigner
donc ce qui veut dire que pendant la
soirée il faut arriver attraper des
verbatim des gens qui disent franchement
bien on s'éclate on s'amuse et c est
tous là tout l'art de ceux qui ont
organisé la soirée c'est de continuer à
la raconter pour préparer le terrain de
la prochaine soirée une fois de plus on
continue à générer de la proximité et de
l'empathie à l'égard d'un public cible
qui sont ces acheteurs
[Musique]
la grande différence entre paris et
dubaï
c'est qu'ici à 2 heures du matin la fête
est finie
ils sont là
sorede un carton s'était plaint des
patrons est vraiment content
non voilà le résultat est bon sur les
prochaine on fera fort encore plus la
différence
ils ont déjà pris rendez-vous du style
pour une autre soirée à dubaï dans
quelques mois encore plus bling bling
paraît-il
à la croix valmer c'est la fin des
vacances lorenzo et angelo les deux
cousins ne sont pas prêts d'oublier leur
soirée à saint tropez
angelo le lyonnais a même tellement aimé
qu'il a pris une grande décision
d'avenir pour moi aussi c'est que je
pense que je vais c'est d'avoir ici
parce que jamal ville ça m'a saoulé et
je me sens bien ici après voilà là c'est
l'été chez qu on va dire je suis un peu
moins sérieux puisque c'est l'été il ya
les fêtes en même temps on voit tout le
monde s'amuse et on a envie de s'amuser
mais l'hiver c'est différent bref au jeu
trouver un boulot à l'année voilà je
passe mon âne à travailler quand ça
arrive les des niveaux de l'été c'est
les vacances voilà la résolution se
croient maîtres bien de l'argent de côté
là cet hiver on sort tout le monde pour
pouvoir en profiter davantage il était
juste devant moi s'excuse à dire c'est
par ici faire encore pire
[Musique]
pour kevin aussi c'est l'heure du retour
à paris après des vacances
il a beaucoup partager avec ses amis
facebook
[Musique]
il vient d'apprendre une drôle de
nouvelle une de ses photos celle ci a
été sélectionné sur le site américain
the rich schizo vince ta g
un site qui regroupe les jeunes qui se
disent les plus riches de la planète
c'est une photo quand même qu'ils qui
est différente
en fait aujourd'hui ce qui plaît c'est
ce qui est différent si c'est pas la vie
de tous les jours qui va susciter de
l'intérêt 8,1 de gens qui aimeraient
être à sa place
gameloft sur cette photo du coup c'est
comme parler de l'argent ce maillot
[Musique]
joy la petite chanteuse la gloire n'est
peut être plus très loin
elle a composé plusieurs nouvelles
chansons et enregistré un nouveau coup
[Musique]